the following content is provided under a Creative Commons license your support
a Creative Commons license your support will help MIT open courseware continue
will help MIT open courseware continue to offer highquality educational
to offer highquality educational resources for free to make a donation or
resources for free to make a donation or view additional materials from hundreds
view additional materials from hundreds of MIT courses visit MIT open courseware
of MIT courses visit MIT open courseware at
ocw.mit.edu hi everyone I am uh I'm Victor my full name
everyone I am uh I'm Victor my full name is Victor Coston I'm a third- year PhD
is Victor Coston I'm a third- year PhD student I'm in uh cell and uh I work in
student I'm in uh cell and uh I work in systems I do mostly security and
systems I do mostly security and distributed systems and I'll be your
distributed systems and I'll be your algorithm ta for this term yay how many
algorithm ta for this term yay how many people went to lecture
yesterday all right are there any parts of the lecture that were particularly
of the lecture that were particularly unclear that you guys want to go
unclear that you guys want to go over so that I uh schedule what I talk
over so that I uh schedule what I talk about in such a way that I'll cover that
about in such a way that I'll cover that more than the parts that are boring and
more than the parts that are boring and obvious
obvious um can you explain complexity uh
um can you explain complexity uh equations I took for2 like three years
equations I took for2 like three years ago
okay what else thank
you some basic outlines for like writing proofs uh relevant to like the presets
else okay we're going to get started then so the hardest and I think most
then so the hardest and I think most important part of U the whole whole
important part of U the whole whole course is learning how to deal with the
course is learning how to deal with the ASM totic complexity so as ASM totic
ASM totic complexity so as ASM totic complexity is this very nice tool where
complexity is this very nice tool where you have a function that looks like
you have a function that looks like this X
this X Plus what do I have here 10
so you have this guy which is quite long and horrible and would make your life
and horrible and would make your life miserable if you'd have to reason about
miserable if you'd have to reason about it and you can say
it and you can say that this
that this is Theta
is Theta of n
of n SED X
sorry so everything that's here goes away and this constant Factor here goes
away and this constant Factor here goes away way and it's a nice and small
away way and it's a nice and small function uh why is that the case first
function uh why is that the case first of all if I
of all if I plot this function and since I don't
plot this function and since I don't have my projector you'll have to take my
have my projector you'll have to take my word for it I will get something that
word for it I will get something that looks like
this if I plot this function I will get something that looks like this this is a
something that looks like this this is a scale from0 to
scale from0 to 200 however if I make my
200 however if I make my scale 0 to
20,000 let's say 200,000 to make sure that it's going to be
that it's going to be correct X squ looks like this and this
function looks like this and as you make the scale bigger
this and as you make the scale bigger and bigger you can't even see this noise
and bigger you can't even see this noise anymore the reason is that all the noise
anymore the reason is that all the noise is
is in this term in the X to the power of
in this term in the X to the power of 1th term
1th term and as n Pretend This is n xn same thing
and as n Pretend This is n xn same thing so as the input to the function gets
so as the input to the function gets bigger and bigger this grows at a much
bigger and bigger this grows at a much faster rate than this so if what I care
faster rate than this so if what I care about is how the function grows I can
about is how the function grows I can ignore
ignore anything aside from the dominant
term do people remember this from lecture does this make
sense okay if it doesn't that's great it means that I'm not wasting time covering
means that I'm not wasting time covering it so we learned about three symbols or
it so we learned about three symbols or we will learn about three symbols when
we will learn about three symbols when talking about the asmic complexity the
talking about the asmic complexity the three symbols are Theta o and
three symbols are Theta o and Omega uh let's say this complicated
Omega uh let's say this complicated function
function is G and this nice simple function is
f if I say that g of X is Theta of F ofx that means two things it means
of F ofx that means two things it means I have a lower bound like I showed
I have a lower bound like I showed here and the lower bound looks something
here and the lower bound looks something like X squ and it means that I also have
like X squ and it means that I also have a higher an upper Bound for it that also
a higher an upper Bound for it that also looks like X squ so the upper bound
looks like X squ so the upper bound would be something like
would be something like this and if I say this then I'm making a
this and if I say this then I'm making a promise that the function stays between
promise that the function stays between the lower bound and the upper bound and
the lower bound and the upper bound and the bounds look sort of the same I can't
the bounds look sort of the same I can't really have X squ here and x squared
really have X squ here and x squared here right that would be impossible so
here right that would be impossible so that's why I said they look the same
that's why I said they look the same they're not the
they're not the same and they're not the same because
same and they're not the same because they're allowed to differ by a constant
they're allowed to differ by a constant Factor so if
Factor so if this is f and say this is f Prime F ofx
this is f and say this is f Prime F ofx might
might be X2 and we know for sure that this is
be X2 and we know for sure that this is going to be lower than this and frime of
going to be lower than this and frime of X might
be 1.2 * x^2 and because I have a 1.1 here and I know that these get smaller
here and I know that these get smaller and smaller in relation to this as the
and smaller in relation to this as the function uh as the inputs to the
function uh as the inputs to the function get bigger I know that this is
function get bigger I know that this is going to be the dominating factor and
going to be the dominating factor and because this is bigger than this this
because this is bigger than this this function is going to eventually be
function is going to eventually be larger than this function so I have a
larger than this function so I have a bound from above and I have a bound from
bound from above and I have a bound from below and the bounds look almost the
below and the bounds look almost the same they're only different by a
same they're only different by a constant Factor this is
constant Factor this is Theta to make things spicier by the way
Theta to make things spicier by the way Theta is really hard to pronounce as
Theta is really hard to pronounce as opposed to O So we usually say and write
opposed to O So we usually say and write o instead of of theta we'll talk about
o instead of of theta we'll talk about what o really means in a bit but if you
what o really means in a bit but if you see o in a lot of places including our
see o in a lot of places including our notes know that most of the time we
notes know that most of the time we actually mean Theta and sorry for that
actually mean Theta and sorry for that when do we know we actually
when do we know we actually mean uh you can ask us and we'll tell
mean uh you can ask us and we'll tell you fortunately it doesn't matter too
you fortunately it doesn't matter too much so we're trying to get an idea of
much so we're trying to get an idea of how the functions look like in the
how the functions look like in the bigger picture so most of the time it
bigger picture so most of the time it doesn't matter I'll give you an example
doesn't matter I'll give you an example though of where it matters and how it
though of where it matters and how it could matter
could matter so suppose I have another function that
so suppose I have another function that looks
looks like I keep doing that that looks like
like I keep doing that that looks like this so this is kind of ugly too uh this
this so this is kind of ugly too uh this function is
function is um G of X say x
um G of X say x *
* 1+ s of
x so I can't say anything about the lower
so I can't say anything about the lower bound of this this is going to hit zero
bound of this this is going to hit zero at an infinite number of values right so
at an infinite number of values right so I can't say that I can't have a nice
I can't say that I can't have a nice lower Bound for it the lower Bound for
lower Bound for it the lower Bound for it is zero but I'm pretty sure that it's
it is zero but I'm pretty sure that it's never going to be bigger than 2x right
never going to be bigger than 2x right and that's still worth something so
and that's still worth something so there's this other function here that's
there's this other function here that's supposed to be a line pretend it's a
supposed to be a line pretend it's a line F ofx = 2X and I know for sure that
line F ofx = 2X and I know for sure that this this is never going to exceed these
this this is never going to exceed these this and in that case where I only have
this and in that case where I only have one upper bound and I don't have a good
one upper bound and I don't have a good lower bound I say that g ofx is order of
lower bound I say that g ofx is order of F ofx and this is where this is what o
F ofx and this is where this is what o really means it means I only have an
really means it means I only have an upper bound and not a lower
upper bound and not a lower Bound in most of the cases when you're
Bound in most of the cases when you're coding something you don't really care
coding something you don't really care how how well your program can run if
how how well your program can run if you're really lucky what you really care
you're really lucky what you really care about is how does it run in the worst
about is how does it run in the worst case or how does it run most of the time
case or how does it run most of the time so suppose you're Google and you're
so suppose you're Google and you're writing your search engine H you have to
writing your search engine H you have to return a result to the user in 200
return a result to the user in 200 milliseconds because they did a study
milliseconds because they did a study that shows that if you return the result
that shows that if you return the result in 400 milliseconds they lose some
in 400 milliseconds they lose some number of users which means they lose
number of users which means they lose some number of billions a year so to
some number of billions a year so to them a guarantee that their algorithms
them a guarantee that their algorithms complete in 200 milliseconds is pretty
complete in 200 milliseconds is pretty important because it means a ton of
important because it means a ton of money so if you have a running time that
money so if you have a running time that looks like this that's okay as long as
looks like this that's okay as long as this is 200 milliseconds for the number
this is 200 milliseconds for the number of pages that Google
of pages that Google indexes does that make
sense okay no answer means yes so if it doesn't make sense please say
something okay I will draw another function again
w what so it's one plus s of
what so it's one plus s of X yeah sorry my handwriting is not very
X yeah sorry my handwriting is not very good it it doesn't really matter what it
good it it doesn't really matter what it is it just needs to it needs to be
is it just needs to it needs to be signed so that it looks wavy like this
signed so that it looks wavy like this so that I can make something that looks
complicated in the first example is it 1.2 yes I wanted something that's higher
1.2 yes I wanted something that's higher than 1.1 so yes
okay now that I got a break um does anyone else want to ask
questions okay so I'm going to draw another function this one looks like
another function this one looks like this and this
is f of x equals um 1 + sin of X I have to use the these signs to make them look
to use the these signs to make them look like
like that times x to the power of what do I
that times x to the power of what do I have there 15 plus x to the power of
1/4 so for this function I know for sure that it is greater than x to the power
that it is greater than x to the power of 1/4 right so if this is
um I know for sure that it's greater than that also if I look at this and I
than that also if I look at this and I know that sign is never bigger than one
know that sign is never bigger than one I know this whole thing is going to be
I know this whole thing is going to be at most two so if I have another
at most two so if I have another function that
function that says um frime of x equals say 3 * x ^ of
says um frime of x equals say 3 * x ^ of 1.5 I know that it's going to bound it
1.5 I know that it's going to bound it from above so I have two
from above so I have two bounds so it sort of looks like this
bounds so it sort of looks like this case except when I I use Theta I have to
case except when I I use Theta I have to make sure that the bounds are very
make sure that the bounds are very similar they can only differ by a
similar they can only differ by a constant factor in this case my bounds
constant factor in this case my bounds differ by the exponent here which is
differ by the exponent here which is more than a constant Factor so they're
more than a constant Factor so they're not the
not the same so if I take my function which by
same so if I take my function which by the way is
the way is G if I want to say that um G to the x is
G if I want to say that um G to the x is Theta of something I can't
Theta of something I can't because no matter what I put in here
because no matter what I put in here it's not going to be
it's not going to be correct the lower bound is this the
correct the lower bound is this the upper bound is
upper bound is this but what I can do is I can say that
this but what I can do is I can say that I know for sure that it is Theta of x to
I know for sure that it is Theta of x to the power of 1/4 and by the way I can
the power of 1/4 and by the way I can also say that it is order of x to the
also say that it is order of x to the power of 1/
15 so if you have weird running times that look like this then you can only
that look like this then you can only use um o and
use um o and Omega and with that being said we will
Omega and with that being said we will use o for pretty much the rest of the
use o for pretty much the rest of the scores and for most of the cases we will
scores and for most of the cases we will use it to mean
Theta oh by the way these formulas look ugly and complicated because I wanted
ugly and complicated because I wanted the graphs to look U complicated to
the graphs to look U complicated to illustrate the idea that uh ASM totic
illustrate the idea that uh ASM totic notation makes things look simpler the
notation makes things look simpler the in this course the running times that
in this course the running times that you'll be dealing with are all look like
you'll be dealing with are all look like this they will either be order one order
this they will either be order one order log
log n
n order n
order n order and log
order and log n and Order N
n and Order N squared you might have a one or two
squared you might have a one or two cases where you get something else but
cases where you get something else but most of the time if you have something
most of the time if you have something else coming out of your recurrence it
else coming out of your recurrence it means you're doing it wrong
means you're doing it wrong so nice tip to have and you can see that
so nice tip to have and you can see that I already started doing it I'm already
I already started doing it I'm already using o instead of
using o instead of theta so I guess I'm getting into the
Habit because whatever I put here is going to be wrong if I put x to the
going to be wrong if I put x to the power of 1/5 this is wrong because I can
power of 1/5 this is wrong because I can have an upper bound that has X to the^
have an upper bound that has X to the^ of 1/5 in it but I can't have a bound
of 1/5 in it but I can't have a bound like that because this function hits x
like that because this function hits x to the power of 1/4 in infinitely many
to the power of 1/4 in infinitely many points if I try to do x to the power of
points if I try to do x to the power of 1/4 same deal lower bound yes upper
1/4 same deal lower bound yes upper bound
bound no so whatever I put in here is going to
no so whatever I put in here is going to be
be wrong thank you good
wrong thank you good question yes or4 uh 1.4 they're 1.4 and
question yes or4 uh 1.4 they're 1.4 and 1.5 okay I thought you were saying one4
1.5 okay I thought you were saying one4 and oh sorry 14 1.4 1.4
far okay let's go through a couple of exercises so I'll give you a few
exercises so I'll give you a few functions yes theega is it's a lower
functions yes theega is it's a lower bound already without multiplying by any
bound already without multiplying by any constant or something is that what it is
constant or something is that what it is so for all of these what you put
so for all of these what you put here is the simple is the simple form so
here is the simple is the simple form so your lower bound can be this function
your lower bound can be this function multiplied by any constant Factor Omega
multiplied by any constant Factor Omega me lower um Omega means lower bound o
me lower um Omega means lower bound o means upper bound Theta means
any other things to clear up before I ask
ask questions so it's your turn before it's
questions so it's your turn before it's my
turn all right I'm going to go over a few functions and I want you guys to
few functions and I want you guys to tell me what um to help me write them in
tell me what um to help me write them in asmic
asmic notation so I will
notation so I will have F of N and I want to know its sta
have F of N and I want to know its sta of
of what so let's start with with f of Nal
what so let's start with with f of Nal 10 to the
10 to the 80 does anyone know why 10 to the
yes okay that's the correct answer you're going ahead though I was
you're going ahead though I was wondering if I was wondering if you know
wondering if I was wondering if you know why why why did I choose this does
why why why did I choose this does anyone know why I chose this
anyone know why I chose this yes uh I think that's
yes uh I think that's 100 you're getting close though it's
100 you're getting close though it's something think it's a really big number
something think it's a really big number it's a really big number all right so
it's a really big number all right so it's a really big number that's the
it's a really big number that's the estimated number of atoms in the
estimated number of atoms in the universe so realistically any quantity
universe so realistically any quantity that you deal with that will represent
that you deal with that will represent the real world is not going to be bigger
the real world is not going to be bigger than
than this so if you want to get all
this so if you want to get all philosophical you can say that for any
philosophical you can say that for any algorithm that you write and any
algorithm that you write and any realistic input the running time will be
realistic input the running time will be Theta of one but if you do this we're
Theta of one but if you do this we're not going to be happy with you on exams
not going to be happy with you on exams so let's choose another
so let's choose another one 20 n to the power of
7th what's this an ASM totic notation and
why yes order of
of okay that's same thing and to the seven
okay that's same thing and to the seven thank you why is that because if you
thank you why is that because if you distribute the exponent s 20 to S just a
distribute the exponent s 20 to S just a Conant excellent 20 to the 7 time n to
Conant excellent 20 to the 7 time n to the 7 this is a constant so it goes
away okay and before I do another one I want to give you guys some help and
want to give you guys some help and remind you about logs how many people
remind you about logs how many people remember the laws of working with logs
remember the laws of working with logs from algebra or some math
from algebra or some math class all right you guys will be helping
class all right you guys will be helping me write them for everyone else so if I
me write them for everyone else so if I have log of n to the 100 and I want to
have log of n to the 100 and I want to get the Theta notation for it what is it
get the Theta notation for it what is it and
case okay so when I have an exponent here I can pull it out in front of the
here I can pull it out in front of the log as a constant Factor so this is the
log as a constant Factor so this is the same thing as
same thing as 100 log
100 log n okay now if I have a logarithm uh to
n okay now if I have a logarithm uh to the base uh using base five of
the base uh using base five of n how about
this l n okay so this is can you say that again log okay so this is theeta of
that again log okay so this is theeta of log n because it
log n because it is
is excellent log n
excellent log n over log
over log five so exponents inside the logs turn
five so exponents inside the logs turn into constant factors bases turn into
into constant factors bases turn into constant
constant factors so if you have a an ugly
factors so if you have a an ugly expression inside the logarithm you can
expression inside the logarithm you can most of the time simplify it to
most of the time simplify it to something really nice and this
something really nice and this contributes to the fact that um these
contributes to the fact that um these are the only functions that you will see
are the only functions that you will see when the answer is cleaned up in asmic
notation okay yes so when you're writing log are you assuming certain base then
log are you assuming certain base then yes there is a certain base for logs uh
yes there is a certain base for logs uh we're all computer scientists right so
we're all computer scientists right so what's the natural base for our
logarithms okay sweet uh math major no yeah I natural Bas okay yeah
major no yeah I natural Bas okay yeah it's a math joke so for everyone else a
it's a math joke so for everyone else a natural logorithm is in Bas e for us CS
natural logorithm is in Bas e for us CS people a natural base is two because
people a natural base is two because that's how many values you have for a
that's how many values you have for a bit
bit so log
means log n is log base 2 of n uh the good news is that most of the
n uh the good news is that most of the time we're working with asmic notation
time we're working with asmic notation so it doesn't really matter we can
so it doesn't really matter we can communicate with our math friends and we
communicate with our math friends and we don't have to talk about
don't have to talk about this okay I need to get another
this okay I need to get another complicated example and my memory fails
okay so log see I'm using Ln to mean the math natural logarithm
math natural logarithm so we still have that somewhere in
so we still have that somewhere in here
here of log n to the base
of log n to the base 100 they made me add all these
100 they made me add all these parentheses in the last section to be
parentheses in the last section to be clear so I'm adding them now from the
clear so I'm adding them now from the start who wants to help me clean this
up yes log l all right wow one step log log
n okay uh can you tell me why very quickly so we can simplify out the base
quickly so we can simplify out the base and the exponent in there okay then base
and the exponent in there okay then base goes out exponent goes out log log of
goes out exponent goes out log log of something is another class complexity
something is another class complexity that's not exactly up there but
that's not exactly up there but occasionally
occasionally yep uh what does a theory students say
yep uh what does a theory students say when they're
drowning log log log log some of you are laughing already you guys know this okay
laughing already you guys know this okay what if I want to make this a little bit
what if I want to make this a little bit harder and
harder and um I
um I say
say log l five
log l five of log n to the
of log n to the 100 you have to do a bit more work now
100 you have to do a bit more work now you can't just use the tricks on the
right anyone else
else yes okay it is still log log n but for a
yes okay it is still log log n but for a different reason
right almost okay maybe not so the base still goes out just like
still goes out just like before but this guy now goes out here so
before but this guy now goes out here so I will have this be sort of
I will have this be sort of like I notice that I'm not saying equal
like I notice that I'm not saying equal I'm saying like because I got rid of the
I'm saying like because I got rid of the base so it's like 100
base so it's like 100 time log n which
time log n which is
is log 100
log 100 plus log log
n and this is a constant Factor this grows as n grows so this is going to
grows as n grows so this is going to become incredibly small as n becomes
become incredibly small as n becomes larger and larger so I can get rid of
it okay
okay okay uh one more and this one's going to
okay uh one more and this one's going to be less
be less boring of 100 going from the last step
boring of 100 going from the last step how are you able to pop it
how are you able to pop it out uh if my memory remember if my
out uh if my memory remember if my memory works I think log of a is log a
memory works I think log of a is log a plus log B am I right guys
sweet good question I'm I wasn't sure but now
good question I'm I wasn't sure but now that you asked everyone else help me
that you asked everyone else help me make sure it's
right okay I'm erasing so much because we're going to need more room for this
we're going to need more room for this so I have a log again but this time what
so I have a log again but this time what I have inside the log is n choose n
I have inside the log is n choose n /2 does any Brave Sol wants to come up
/2 does any Brave Sol wants to come up here and Sol this for
no you guys are going to make me ride for the entire
yep n factorial Over N / 2 factorial times then / 2
times then / 2 factorial
close and I'll give out another hint which is that n factorial can be
which is that n factorial can be approximated as Square < TK of 2 pi n
approximated as Square < TK of 2 pi n multiplied by n / e / n uh to the power
multiplied by n / e / n uh to the power of n but I think this will make you guys
of n but I think this will make you guys not want to come up and Sol this
yes I was is that it is that not it did I get
was is that it is that not it did I get it wrong okay
I I think that's an ASM totic that's that's what we'll I think we'll get to
that's what we'll I think we'll get to that but factorials grow
that but factorials grow exponentially so it should be something
exponentially so it should be something like
like this okay so we have that nice
this okay so we have that nice approximation does anyone want to work
approximation does anyone want to work it out or will I have to do
it keep that in mind when I'm grading your
your homework okay so it's log of square < TK
homework okay so it's log of square < TK 2 pi n
2 pi n MTI power
MTI power n I'm going to put these two together
n I'm going to put these two together so 2
so 2 pi and
pi and over there's an N / two there right so
over there's an N / two there right so it's n / 2
etimes N / 2 the Power of
Two okay I can get rid of this guy because it's a
because it's a constant I can get no I can't get rid of
constant I can get no I can't get rid of this guy yet
thein under the rad yep 2 pi and over two so this
rad yep 2 pi and over two so this simplifies okay thank
simplifies okay thank you sare the bottom and get
andc expon okay can help me thanks so much
okay so we can distribute this exponent here to cancel this and then we get a
here to cancel this and then we get a square root of
Pi sorry my hand I think it's better than mine by quite a
than mine by quite a bit square root
cancels yeah that's probably good so um since this is a n e to the n and n to e
since this is a n e to the n and n to e to the end well since they're to the end
to the end well since they're to the end um both the N we can uh keep them as a
um both the N we can uh keep them as a single exponent cancel stuff so we just
single exponent cancel stuff so we just get
get uh square root of Pi n the * 2 the N
uh square root of Pi n the * 2 the N over Pi
n can do some more cancelling and just get uh to the n
going to simplify this to the end over the square root
the square root of and uh we can take out the pi because
of and uh we can take out the pi because it's an natural logorithm and it's a
it's an natural logorithm and it's a constant factor and this
constant factor and this is log
then since it's a log of it's just a log of 2 the N so it's
uh um say since it's a log you can take out you can turn into log of 2 the N
out you can turn into log of 2 the N minus log of squ n uh log of two to the
minus log of squ n uh log of two to the N is a much greater complexity than
N is a much greater complexity than square of n so we can sweet thank
square of n so we can sweet thank you so see complicated formula even more
you so see complicated formula even more complicated formula came out to be one
complicated formula came out to be one of the numbers that I promised it would
of the numbers that I promised it would come out to thanks for the help so you
come out to thanks for the help so you can get rid of the pi as soon as you
can get rid of the pi as soon as you want to and this is the last step I I
want to and this is the last step I I just want to say it again to make sure
just want to say it again to make sure everyone heard it so once you get here
everyone heard it so once you get here you get this order n
you get this order n minus log of square Ro TK of n which
minus log of square Ro TK of n which is
this is order n minus one half log n and the log n is much smaller
half log n and the log n is much smaller than n so this goes away completely and
than n so this goes away completely and you get this as your final
sense any questions anyone how many people are still paying
anyone how many people are still paying attention
attention honestly wow
honestly wow nice you should come to all my
okay let's talk about something we covered in class let's talk about Peak
covered in class let's talk about Peak finding and we'll start with ond Peak
finding and we'll start with ond Peak finding and then we'll go to 2D pick
finding and then we'll go to 2D pick finding so does anyone remember the
finding so does anyone remember the pseudo code for the faster 1D pick
pseudo code for the faster 1D pick finding by any
chance ond Peak
finding I think everyone said they went to lecture so I don't have to explain
to lecture so I don't have to explain what Peak finding is right
okay let's go for it so suppose I have a few numbers uh three let me write this
few numbers uh three let me write this three four five six
three four five six 7 6
54 so the pick finding problem says there's an array of numbers and I want
there's an array of numbers and I want to find the local Peak and the local
to find the local Peak and the local Peak is a number that surrounded by
Peak is a number that surrounded by numbers that are smaller or equal to it
numbers that are smaller or equal to it so there shouldn't be any larger numbers
so there shouldn't be any larger numbers than it and I want to find a peak as
than it and I want to find a peak as quickly as I
quickly as I can so what's the faster algorithm that
can so what's the faster algorithm that we talked about in
lecture yes okay you didn't answer right as much at least
as much at least so yeah binary search okay it's exactly
so yeah binary search okay it's exactly like binary search yep uh do help me
like binary search yep uh do help me write the pseudo code you can tell me
write the pseudo code you can tell me what it
what it is start midle
middle if you if you write this on uh on your pet you might want to be a little
your pet you might want to be a little bit more formal someone asked me about
bit more formal someone asked me about proofs I would say something like start
proofs I would say something like start by looking at the middle element of the
by looking at the middle element of the array same thing
array same thing though
though okay so let's pretend this is the
okay so let's pretend this is the middle now it
middle now it is what do I
do okay I'm looking at the right side I see a seven there so I know for sure
see a seven there so I know for sure that this is not a local Peak
that this is not a local Peak right what do I do
now okay uh what if this would be small what if I
uh what if this would be small what if I would look at five
would look at five first or shouldn't should I look at the
first or shouldn't should I look at the other side too well you don't have to in
other side too well you don't have to in this case but if you but if seven were
this case but if you but if seven were smaller then you would go and look at
smaller then you would go and look at the other side to check to see five was
the other side to check to see five was also smaller in that case You' already
also smaller in that case You' already found it okay so I have to look at both
found it okay so I have to look at both sides and make sure if none of them is
sides and make sure if none of them is smaller then I sorry if none of them is
smaller then I sorry if none of them is bigger I found a peak if any of them is
bigger I found a peak if any of them is uh bigger then I can go whichever way I
uh bigger then I can go whichever way I want so I saw my seven I'm going to cut
want so I saw my seven I'm going to cut this in half and now I look at this
this in half and now I look at this you're saying
right so look at neighbors by the way can anyone
neighbors by the way can anyone understand my handwriting is it even
understand my handwriting is it even worth bothering to
worth bothering to write okay I see three nods I'm going to
write okay I see three nods I'm going to write for those three
write for those three people look at years
people look at years so okay thanks not feeling old at all
so okay thanks not feeling old at all okay look at neighbors uh figure out if
okay look at neighbors uh figure out if you're a peak you're one of the people
you're a peak you're one of the people that said you can read it so now there's
that said you can read it so now there's only two people that can read my
only two people that can read my handwriting and that I
handwriting and that I like uh look at the
like uh look at the neighbors see if local
recurse so what's the running time for this suppose I have n elements to start
this suppose I have n elements to start with that's my array size I will use T
with that's my array size I will use T of
of n as my running time so to figure out
n as my running time so to figure out the running time for the whole algorithm
the running time for the whole algorithm I have to look at the running time for
I have to look at the running time for each step and add them up right what's
each step and add them up right what's the running time for the first step look
the running time for the first step look in the
middle one one I I would not say it's zero I still have to look at it
zero I still have to look at it or to be on the safe side you say one
or to be on the safe side you say one Theta of one it's a
Theta of one it's a constant okay now I have to look at the
constant okay now I have to look at the neighbors and I have to see if one of
neighbors and I have to see if one of them is bigger or not how about that how
them is bigger or not how about that how much time is that
I heard the constant okay very soft voice but I heard a constant there so
voice but I heard a constant there so I'm going to take it so this guy is a
I'm going to take it so this guy is a constant if it's a local pick I'm down
constant if it's a local pick I'm down if it's not a local pick what's the
if it's not a local pick what's the running time for
this yep so I'm looking at this guy it's
yep so I'm looking at this guy it's clearly not a peak so I'm going to look
clearly not a peak so I'm going to look in the right side because I see a seven
in the right side because I see a seven here that's bigger than a six so now I
here that's bigger than a six so now I have the same problem except my array
have the same problem except my array size just dropped to half so same
size just dropped to half so same problem because I already have a name
problem because I already have a name for it except the input size is
for it except the input size is different so the running time for this
different so the running time for this entire step
entire step is Theta of 1 + T of n /2 so the running
is Theta of 1 + T of n /2 so the running time for the whole thing
time for the whole thing is um I should have said Theta of 1 here
is um I should have said Theta of 1 here sorry so Theta of 1 plus Theta of 1 + T
sorry so Theta of 1 plus Theta of 1 + T of n / 2 so this is Theta of
of n / 2 so this is Theta of 1+ T of n /
1+ T of n / 2 so I wrote out my pseudo code looked
2 so I wrote out my pseudo code looked at the running time for each step added
at the running time for each step added them up now I have a recurrence and I
them up now I have a recurrence and I have to solve it let's solve it we sort
have to solve it let's solve it we sort of glossed over that in lectures so
of glossed over that in lectures so we're going to do it
now so T of n equals Theta of 1 + T of n / 2 I'm going to expand this using the
/ 2 I'm going to expand this using the definition and and Theta of one is long
definition and and Theta of one is long so I'm going to call this C instead it's
so I'm going to call this C instead it's a constant right so C plus expanding
a constant right so C plus expanding this C + T of n / 4 I'm going to expand
this C + T of n / 4 I'm going to expand it
again anyone getting bir of this so if I expand it a lot of times
this so if I expand it a lot of times I'm going to get I * C + T of n / by 2
I'm going to get I * C + T of n / by 2 to the I and you can expand it as many
to the I and you can expand it as many times as you want until we see the
times as you want until we see the pattern but this is the
pattern but this is the pattern so I have a recurrence what else
pattern so I have a recurrence what else do I need in order to get a function I
do I need in order to get a function I need a base case so the problem size get
need a base case so the problem size get smaller and smaller and smaller but at
smaller and smaller and smaller but at some point it becomes so small that I
some point it becomes so small that I can solve it just by looking at it
can solve it just by looking at it what's that case
okay so if I have an array of one element it's a peak right job
element it's a peak right job done so T of one
done so T of one is a
is a constant so I want to write this in such
constant so I want to write this in such a way that this
a way that this becomes
becomes this so I want to figure out an I such
this so I want to figure out an I such that
um yeah t of n / 2 to the I equals T of one and the easi way of doing that
T of one and the easi way of doing that is to say that n / 2 to the I is 1 so I
is to say that n / 2 to the I is 1 so I is the inverse of an
is the inverse of an exponential
anyone logarithm thank you
you log
log n so I have I and I'm going to plug it
n so I have I and I'm going to plug it back in here and I get constant
back in here and I get constant times log
times log n+ T of 1 which I know is Theta of
n+ T of 1 which I know is Theta of one um I'm going to make this Theta of 1
one um I'm going to make this Theta of 1 again so Theta of 1
again so Theta of 1 * log n+ plus Thea of 1 and I know that
* log n+ plus Thea of 1 and I know that log n dominates a constant so this is
log n dominates a constant so this is going to be Theta of log
solve okay how are we doing yes and second to last from the
doing yes and second to last from the bottom I
bottom I understand
understand C
C I and second part of equation how
I and second part of equation how you okay so uh in the jump from here to
you okay so uh in the jump from here to here where I said I equals log n
here where I said I equals log n right okay so I becomes log n c stays C
right okay so I becomes log n c stays C you're wondering about this part
you're wondering about this part right so if I is log n then 2 to the I
right so if I is log n then 2 to the I is n so I have t of one which I have
is n so I have t of one which I have here so
here so I wanted to have this happen when I was
I wanted to have this happen when I was solving for I here I set this guy to my
solving for I here I set this guy to my base case so that I can get this to
happen the idea here is that you're expanding the recursion forever and you
expanding the recursion forever and you know that at some point you're going to
know that at some point you're going to have to stop when do you stop you stop
have to stop when do you stop you stop at the base case so you force this to
at the base case so you force this to become the base
case okay
okay uh let's do 2D Peak finding let's talk about it a little
bit so 2D pick finding is exactly like 1D Pi finding except you have a 2d
1D Pi finding except you have a 2d Matrix instead of a 1D
Matrix instead of a 1D array
array uh let's see if I can do this
right so suppose this is our Matrix and suppose
suppose these are the rows suppose we have um M
okay can anyone remind me what the pseudo code for for 2D Peak finding that
pseudo code for for 2D Peak finding that we talked about in lecture so we had two
we talked about in lecture so we had two attempts the first one was a clear
attempts the first one was a clear failure it didn't work the second one
failure it didn't work the second one worked and we talked about it running
worked and we talked about it running time a little bit and then FY asked you
time a little bit and then FY asked you to think of a variation to the second
to think of a variation to the second one so let's do the straight up second
one so let's do the straight up second uh version of the pseudo code without
uh version of the pseudo code without the
the variation so 2D pick
algorithm all right one person was not asleep in my section at the end of
asleep in my section at the end of lecture I'm
lecture I'm proud which one of
proud which one of us uh you had your hand up first though
us uh you had your hand up first though so you just
so you just a
a okay
okay and
Peak neighbors neighbors in the same
neighbors neighbors in the same row yeah yeah
row yeah yeah sorry row is the horizontal one right
sorry row is the horizontal one right okay so what do you mean by find the
okay so what do you mean by find the peak
peak here with the coln yes so find the peak
here with the coln yes so find the peak using what we talked about before yeah
okay find One D
peek so you're thinking ahead you're thinking of the variation that sh asked
thinking of the variation that sh asked you guys to think about at home I'm glad
you guys to think about at home I'm glad you thought about it that's good but uh
you thought about it that's good but uh what's the one that we had in lecture I
what's the one that we had in lecture I want to think about I don't want to give
want to think about I don't want to give you guys the answer yet so what did we
you guys the answer yet so what did we say we're going to do in
say we're going to do in lecture yes I think we just picked a
lecture yes I think we just picked a spot check the neighbors and kept
spot check the neighbors and kept walking uphill if that makes sense every
walking uphill if that makes sense every time we found a neighbor that was bigger
time we found a neighbor that was bigger move to that
move to that spot so this is this is the first
spot so this is this is the first algorithm that's slow it works you're
algorithm that's slow it works you're going to get the correct answer but it's
going to get the correct answer but it's slow because if you have some uh handly
slow because if you have some uh handly crafted uh Matrix you can go like this
crafted uh Matrix you can go like this and you're basically going through the
and you're basically going through the whole
whole Matrix yes uh I think the second
Matrix yes uh I think the second algorithm was find a look through the
algorithm was find a look through the column for its maximum and then look to
column for its maximum and then look to either side okay so instead of finding a
either side okay so instead of finding a 1D Peak we're going to find the maximum
value okay and this is correct and let's look at this running
time does anyone want to help me so this is T
is T of n m right and rows and
of n m right and rows and columns so what's the running time for
columns so what's the running time for the first
the first step come on this is the easy one yes
step come on this is the easy one yes it's a constant
perfect okay what's the running time for finding a maximum out of n
finding a maximum out of n numbers
numbers okay
okay perfect and suppose we do that
perfect and suppose we do that here suppose these rows don't exist
here suppose these rows don't exist suppose this is my entire Matrix and I'm
suppose this is my entire Matrix and I'm here and I found a maximum what do I do
here and I found a maximum what do I do I look left I look right if both of them
I look left I look right if both of them are smaller then it means I found my
are smaller then it means I found my Peak because I know that number was a
Peak because I know that number was a maximum in my column now if that's not
maximum in my column now if that's not the case if I find a number that's
the case if I find a number that's bigger I'll go in that direction does
bigger I'll go in that direction does that un
that un reasonable okay so maximum for my column
reasonable okay so maximum for my column and I'm going to go
and I'm going to go right so check neighbors and I have the
right so check neighbors and I have the same two conditions
same two conditions there if it's a peak then I'm
there if it's a peak then I'm happy otherwise
happy otherwise recurse so what's the running time if I
recurse so what's the running time if I have to recurse how does the new problem
have to recurse how does the new problem look
look like it's an identical problem I still
like it's an identical problem I still have a matrix except what
have a matrix except what changed so suppose I got here and this
changed so suppose I got here and this is the middle of my Matrix and I see
is the middle of my Matrix and I see that this guy is bigger so I'm going to
that this guy is bigger so I'm going to recurse to the right
recurse to the right side what happened to my problem
size okay sorry I'm not answering question but um should find Max not
question but um should find Max not n let me see tell uh you are right thank
n let me see tell uh you are right thank you for paying
you for paying attention there I am sweet that would
attention there I am sweet that would have Tri me up later thanks for saving
have Tri me up later thanks for saving me okay so your question sorry so the
me okay so your question sorry so the question is if I have to
question is if I have to recurse what's the running
time so I'm if I have to recurse I'm in this array that was originally n by
this array that was originally n by m and I'm only going to look at the
m and I'm only going to look at the right
side how many these how many rows do I have in
many these how many rows do I have in the new array start with a easy
one all right same as before how many
before how many columns n/
columns n/ two sweet so the recursion for this is
two sweet so the recursion for this is Theta of 1 plus Theta of
Theta of 1 plus Theta of M plus T
M plus T of n / 2 and
of n / 2 and M uh I know that a constant can be
M uh I know that a constant can be absorbed by this other guy so it's Theta
absorbed by this other guy so it's Theta of M plus T of n / 2
of M plus T of n / 2 m how would I solve
this what's the first thing that we need yes figure out base case all right
need yes figure out base case all right excellent base case what's the B what's
excellent base case what's the B what's the base
okay sweet so if I only have one column
sweet so if I only have one column then I can do I can find the maximum and
then I can do I can find the maximum and I know for sure that's going to be a
I know for sure that's going to be a peak job done that's my base case so I'm
peak job done that's my base case so I'm going to reduce the problem size in half
going to reduce the problem size in half until I get to a single column then I
until I get to a single column then I find the peak there and I'm
find the peak there and I'm happy uh how would I solve this
recurrence it's a one minute answer because I think that's exactly how much
because I think that's exactly how much time we have as a
come on guys this looks familiar yes exactly
yes exactly function exactly M never changes right
function exactly M never changes right so this is basically a function of n so
so this is basically a function of n so if M never changes and I pretend that
if M never changes and I pretend that it's a constant this looks exactly like
it's a constant this looks exactly like the recursion the recurrence that we Sol
the recursion the recurrence that we Sol before T of N is a constant plus T of n
before T of N is a constant plus T of n uh over
uh over two
two so I'm going to get that
so I'm going to get that constant multiplied by log n which is
constant multiplied by log n which is the solution that I had before so the
the solution that I had before so the running time is Theta of M log
running time is Theta of M log n all right I think I have 30 seconds so
n all right I think I have 30 seconds so what if I would choose what if I would
what if I would choose what if I would try to do this algorithm instead it's
try to do this algorithm instead it's another one minute question so I guess
another one minute question so I guess I'm cheating I'm taking time away sorry
I'm cheating I'm taking time away sorry so what if I would be finding a One D
so what if I would be finding a One D Peak instead of finding a
maximum I'm looking at the running time because if the running time is going to
because if the running time is going to be the same is not even worth thinking
be the same is not even worth thinking if it's correct or not if it's a more
if it's correct or not if it's a more complicated algorithm with the same
complicated algorithm with the same running time why care about it so is the
running time why care about it so is the running time going to be
running time going to be better okay I heard an OD
why all right so One D Pick is exactly what we have there thank you one D Pick
what we have there thank you one D Pick is is exactly like you said log M so
is is exactly like you said log M so this constant here becomes this constant
this constant here becomes this constant here so the algorithm would be a lot
here so the algorithm would be a lot faster U as an order of magnitude idea
faster U as an order of magnitude idea if your M and N are 1 million each then
if your M and N are 1 million each then log n is 20 so that's a 50 time x
log n is 20 so that's a 50 time x Improvement and these are real input
Improvement and these are real input sizes you might
sizes you might get and that's it thank you guys